[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء في حصاد الليله
معكم حسن جمود وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
تقع واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى
صورنا المباشره هذه الليله تركز على
انتخابات التجديد النصفي في الكونجرس
الامريكي والتي يتواصل الاضطراع فيها
هذه صور المباشره من ولايه بنسلفانيا اذا
قد تعتمد الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكيه عليها ويدور الصراع حول مقعد
شاغر تركه عضو جمهوري في المجلس
ومن اريزونا هذه الصور المباشره من
الولايه التي توصف الانتخابات فيها بانها
وحيده من اكثر المعارك السياسيه اهميه في
الانتخابات النصفيه بالنسبه لمستقبل
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
الامريكيون يواصلون الاقتراع في انتخابات
حاسمه لتجديد النصفي لاعضاء الكونغرس
الناخبين على التصويت والدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه ويقول ان بامكانهم احداث فارق
في الانتخابات
والجمهوريون يسعون الانتزاع اغلبيه في
مجلس الكونغرس
ومع تقدم عمليات التصويت تراقب لمصير
الولايات المتاحه بن سلفانيا وجورجيا
واريزونا ونفادا
ونورس كارولينا تحسين سباق التجديد
النصفيه احتدام للمنافسه في تجديد مجلس
النواب وغموض بشان النتائج المتوقعه في
سباق مجلس الشيوخ
بعد اعلان موسكو استعدادها لحوار مع
واشنطن تقارير عن استئناف مرتقب للمحادثات
بشان السلاح النووي خلال اسابيع
موسكو تقول انها لم تتفاوض مع الامريكيين
بشان اوكرانيا وتعلن جاهزيتها لاستئناف
المفاوضات معتياز بدون اي شروط مسبقه
واوكرانيا تشترط انسحاب القوه الروسيه من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه قبل اي تفاوض
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه
ناقشنا تصويت عشرات ملايين الامريكيين في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونجرس
انتخابات توصف بالحسيمه هناك عدد من
القضايا التي تتصدر اهتمامات الناخبين
الامريكيين مثل الوضع الاقتصادي والتضخم
وقضايا اجتماعيه مثل الهجره والاجهاض
وانتشار الجريمه ومستقبل الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه وتداعيات قضايا تتعلق بالسياسه
الخارجيه مثل حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما هي
القضايا الاكثر اهميه بالنسبه للناخب
الامريكي
خمسون في المئه اعتبر وان القضايا
الاقتصاديه هي الاكثر اهميه بينما 40%
اولو اهميه كبرى للقضايا الاجتماعيه اما
10%
الامريكي مهتم بدرجه اكبر بالسياسه
الخارجيه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على من الصوت
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز الظاهر على الشاشه
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطررق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
مشاهدينا مباشره الى عثمان اي فرح في
واشنطن ونافذه من هناك لمواصله تغطيه
انتخابات التجديد النصفي للكونغرس
الامريكي
[موسيقى]
شكرا لحسن تجاوزنا الثالث ظهرا بتوقيت
واشنطن ونواصل معكم تغطياتنا من العاصمه
الامريكيه اليوم الاقتراع في الانتخابات
النصفيهون باصواتهم في انحاء الولايات
المتحده لاختيار الكونجرس الجديد لاضافه
الى انتخاب حكام معظم الولايات ومسؤوليها
المحليين وكذلك المجالس التشريعيه
للولايات
الرئيس الامريكي جو فايدن قال في تغريده
ان لدى لحزب الديمقراطي فرصه لاعاده بناء
الولايات المتحده بطريقه افضل للجميع
واضاف بايدنا ان الجوريين يسعون لاعاده
البلاد الى الوراء على حد تعبيره
وقد ادلى الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بصوته في مدينه بان بيتش في ولايه
فلوريدا وابدا ترامب تفاؤله بشان نتائج
الانتخابات مشيرا الى انها ستكون ليله
عظيمه للجمهوريين بحسب تعبير
وفي فلوريدا ايضا ذكرت شبكه سي ان ان
مسؤولين في الولايه ابلغ وزاره العدل
بانهم لن يسمحوا بدخول مراقبي الانتخابات
الفدراليين الى مراكز الاقتراع في انحاء
الولايه كافه وذلك مراعاه مراعاه للقوانين
المحليه وقال المسؤولون في رساله الى
وزاره العدل ان المراقبين الفيدراليين غير
مدرجنا على لائحه الاشخاص المسموح لهم
بالدخول الى مراكز الاقتراع
في الاثناء قال همم مركز الوطني للاعاصير
الى العاصمه العاصفه المدمر نيكول تحركت
باتجاه ساحلي ولايه فلوريدا الثلاثاء ومن
المتوقع ان تتطور الى اعصار خلال اليومين
المقبلين حسب وسائل الاعلاميه ويخشى من ان
تؤثر عاصفه نيكول على عمليه فرز الاصوات
في عدد من المناطق الساحليه في الولايه
واعلنت سلطاته مدينه بان بيتش انه سيتم
اغلاق المدارس والمكاتب الحكوميه يوميه
الاربعاء والخميس فيما تواصل العاصفه
الاغتراب من الساحل الشرقي
وكانت السلطات المحليه في ولايه اريزون
كانت قد اشارت الى وقوع اكثر من 18 حاله
ترهيب الناخبين على مدى الاسابيع الماضيه
واعلن مكتب سكرتيره ارينا ان حالات
الترهيب المسجله تم رصدها منذ بدء مرحله
الاقتراع المبكر في الثانيه عشر من من
تشرين الاول اكتوبر الماضي واضاف انه جرى
تحويله هذه الشكاوى الى وكالات انفاذ
القانون المحليه والفيدراليه
هذا وكشف مسؤول في اللجان الانتخابيه
التابعه لمدينه فليدلفيا الامريكيه في
ولايه بنسلفانيا احتمال الغاء نحو ثلاثه
الاف و600 بطاقه اختراع عبر البريد واشار
المسؤول في مقابله مع شبكه سين ان استبعاد
بطاقات الاختراع المعنيه قد يتم على خلفيه
تضمنها معلومات غير صحيحه او عدم استفاؤها
عددا من الشروط واضاف المسؤول انه لا يزال
بامكان الناخبين الذين تم استبعاده
بطاقتهم ان يدلوا باصواتهم عبر الحضور الى
مراكز الاقتراع اليوم
الان الى شبكه مراسلين نذهب الى بن
سيلفينيا معنا من هناك مراسل الجزيره محمد
الاحمد وينضم الينا طبعا شبكه المراسلين
مختلفه من اتلانت في ولايه جورجيا احمد
هزيم وينضم الينا من امام مراكز الاختراع
في مدينه ميامي في ولايه فلوريدام مراسل
الجزيره مراد هاشم
حسنا اذا بدات من ميامي في فلوريدا
فلوريدا يحدث فيها الكثير يبدو مراد هناك
العاصفه نيكول التي تخترب وهناك امور
تتعلق بعدم السماح لمراقبين الفيدراليين
اطلعنا على مجمل لسوره من فضلك
بالفعل عثمان ومجمل هذه التطورات التي
اشرت اليها وغيرها ايضا من مبعث القلق
لديمقراطيين
حاليا الان نرى نحن في مركز الاقتراع هذا
الذي يقع في قلب منطقه ديمقراطيه بدانا
نشهد بعض الحشود من الطوابير الى خارج
المركز في المعتاد ومنذ الصباح كانت
الطوابير داخل هذا المركز ما يعني ان همم
الناقلين بداوا يتوافدون باعداد كبيره لكن
في حاله طول الامطار كما حدث في الظهيره
همم فان هذا ايضا قد يثني همم ويؤثر قد
يثني على الناقبين من الحضور بعد اعمالهم
الى هذا المركز وهذا مبعث قال ديمقراطي
ولا سيما همم انه همم الكثير من المناطق
لم تتعافى بعد حتى من اثار
ايان الذي ضرب قبل سته اسابيع ولا يزال
هناك
النحو مليون من المسجلين في ثلاثه مقاطعات
متاثرين بهذا الاعصار واتخذت اجراءات
استثنائيه
لتسهيل عمليه تصويطهم لاسيما ان هناك
المئات منهم فقدوا منازلهم وبالتالي تعين
تغيير مراكز اقتراعهم وكذلك استحداث مراكز
اقتراع لهم ال هذا القلق قد يتلاشى فيما
يتعلق بعمليه التصويت اذا مررت عمليه
التصويت التي مضى عليها الان اكثر من ثمان
ساعات همم بقي بدعه ساعات حتى تغلق مراكز
الاقتراع ابوابها في السابعه همم تبدا
بعدها عمليات الفرز وسيكون هناك قلق كما
يتعلق بعمليه الفرز اذا همم بدات مقدمات
هذه العاصفه همم
تضرب هنا في مقاطعه همم ما يعني بطبيعه
الحال هناك
ديمقراطيه ايضا حتى في ما يتعلق بالتصويت
عبر البريد وكانت النائبه الديمقراطيه همم
تواصل من شاطس عبرت عن قلقها من هذه
المساله لان نظرا لما حدث في الانتخابات
السابقه من ان هناك بطاقات للمئات من
البطاقات لم اتصل في الوقت المناسب ولم
تحسب ولم يتم همم فرزها حاليا في هذه
الانتخابات همم هناك اكثر من 4 ملايين
و300,000 بطاقه بريد طلبت للاقتراع اعيد
منها مليونين ونصف المليون بطاقه اغلب
المصوتين همم في البطاقات العائده هم من
الديمقراطيين بنسبه 43% مقابل 37 الى 38
الى الجمهوريه وبالتالي التصويت عبر
البريد يصف لصالح الديمقراطين ولهذا هم
اقالقون في هذه المساله وحريصون على ان
تتم عمليه الاجراءات في مراكز البريد بشكل
سريع لتصل البطاقات في موعدها اذا انها
اذا وصلت بعد السابعه مساء من يوم
الاختراع بعد السابعه مساء من اليوم فانها
همم تحتسب من مباحث القلق الديمقراطي ايضا
عثمان الاثار الذين جمعتنا عن اعاده تقسيم
الدوائر
التكتلات الديمقراطيه الكبرى هنا في
الولايه والتي كنا نراها تكتلات زرقاء في
الخريطه السابقه الى ما قبل 2020 في
تلاهاسي عاصمه الولايه والتام باشا غرب
الولايه واولاندو ايضا في وسط الولايه
وهنا في ميامي مقاطعه ميامي وجوارها ايضا
المحسوبه على الديمقراطيه تم تقسيمها بشكل
اا يخدم الحزب الجمهوري بشكل كبير وهذا
كله الان في هذه في هذا اليوم حيث نرى
الكثير من الاستطلاعات بالفعل تحسم
اتجاهات التصويت لصالح الديمقراطيين لصالح
الجمهوريين حتى في دوائر
عده اعتمرت لفترات طويله من معاقل
الديمقراطين لا تزال مع ذلك هناك دوائر
محسومه لي الديمقراطين ولكن اعدادها همم
تقلب بشكل همم كبير همم الديمقراطيون
فازوا في الانتخابات السابقه هنا في هذه
الولايه ب 11 مقعدا من 27 اي كانت هناك
الجمهوريه 16 مقعدا الجو الديمقراطيون
النظري لترشح عدد من شخصياتهم او اثنين من
شخصياتهم فقدوا مقعدين هم ممثلون الان
بتسعه مقاعد قد يخسروا المزيد في هذه
الانتخابات بطبيعه الحال كما خسروا المزيد
كذلك في انتخابات سابقه على مستوى مجلس
النواب بطبيعه الحال هناك ايضا في الجانب
الجمهوري حاله من الانتشار فيما يتعلق
بالمؤشرات كلها مؤشرات التسجيل ارقام
كبيره للجمهوريه تتجاوز الديمقراطيين من
الناقبين المسجلين المؤشرات الاستطلاعات
التي تعطي بها افضليه كبيره وبين نسب
كبيره لمرشح الحزب الجمهوريه على مستويات
السباق همم كافه همم ايضا فيما يتعلق
بالمستويات المشاركه اختراع المبكر لاسيما
بالمشاركه بالتصويت الشخصي اذ تغلب فيه
الجمهوريون بنسبه بنسبه 43% مقابل 37%
للديمقراطيين عثمان اذا هي معركه
ومواجهه حاسمه هنا في همم كل قد
تؤكد بالفعل التوقعات التي تشير الى ان
هذه الولايه ستخرج تماما من قائمه
الولايات المتاحه وسخرها الديمقراطيون
بالطبيعه بطبيعه الحال وسيخسرون اصواتها
في الكليه الانتخابيه لاحقا في انتخابات
الرئاسه القادمه عثمان
نعم يعني في المجمل الاستطلاعات الراي
تذهب لصالح الجمهوريين ولكن بشكل ربما
اوضح في فلوريدا يعني سنرى ما الذي يمكن
ان يحدث اذا انتقلنا الى جورجيا وانا اراك
احمد هزيم يبدو انك في نفس المكان الذي
كان فيه مؤتمر صحفي قبل قليل سكرتير
الولايه ولايه جورجيا ما الذي قيل في هذا
المؤتمر وكيف تسير عمليه الاقتراع عن كل
شيء على ما يرام
نعم عثمان هنا هو المركز اللي جاره عمليات
الانتخابات والمراقبه اي المركز الذي
يستخدم الشكاوي ويراقب سير العمليات يراقب
الطوابير واوقات متوسطه
ينتظرها
بصوته كان هناك مؤتمر الصحفيه كما ذكرت
سكرتير الولايه
ذكر بان متوسط الانتظار بالنسبه في مراكز
الاقتراعونات الولايه ثلاث دقائق
ومتوسط التحقق من هويه وثبوتيه الناخب
تستغرق 49 ثانيه وهنا يرد على اولئك الذين
كانوا
القانون الانتخابي الجديد لجوريه والذي
قالوا هنا قالوا انه سيؤدي الى الطوابير
كبيره وسيعطل عمليه تصويت هنا يرد وهو
بهذه الارقام على هذه الانتقادات لكن
الوقت لا زال مبكرا الكل يعرف هنا في
ولايه جورجيا انا الطوابير تبدا منذر منذ
بعد الرابعه عصرا عندما يغادر المو ونروح
للعلم ان يوم الانتخابات ليس يوم اجازه
هنا في الولايات المتحده يغادر الموظفون
ويذهبون الى مراكز الاقتراع للابداعي
باصواتهم سيلارا كيف تبدو الصوره حينها في
بعد بعد الرابعه عصرا تحدث هو ايضا عن ان
القانون الجديد سيغير من اليه فرز الاصوات
لتفادي ما حصل في عام 2020 ويبدا من الان
فرز الاصوات اصوات التصويت همم المبكر
وحتى اصوات همم بنصوته عبر البريد بطاقات
من صوته عبر البريل لكي يتم احتسابهم بعد
اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع ولا تتم ولا يحدث
ما حدث في عام 2020 عندما تم حسابهم
بيتاخرا وبدا وكان الرئيس همم السابق
دونالد ترامب هو الفائز قبل ان تنقلب
نتيجه وفتح الباب حينها لنظريات المؤامره
ومزاعا عمليه سرقه الانتخابات لذلك هذا
التغيير ايضا قد يحد من الفرصه لدى
المشككين في الانتخابات في الهجوم على نزا
الانتخابات هنا في ولايه جورجيا وايضا
سيسرع من عمليه اصدار نتائج وحسمها خلال
المساء عندما بعد ان تغلق صناديق الاقتراع
عثمان في بالنسبه للسباق السباق حتى
اللحظه سباق محتدم
تفضل عثمان
هل يعني هذا ان النتائج في جورجيا قد لا
تتاخر مع ما ذكرته من انه يعني من الامور
قد قد تسرع المساله هل هل هناك ضمانه بان
النتيجه سوف تكون الليله في في
حسب ما ذكر في المؤتمر الصحفي ثانويه توقع
ان تظهر غالبيه النتائج غالبيه وليس كلها
بحلول التاسعه مساء هنا بتوقيت جورجيا هو
التوقيت واشنطن بطبيعه الحال اي ان عمليه
العمليه استبدا نتائج الاوليه بالظهور
الساعه 9:00 وسيختتم ربما النتائج
النهائيه مع حلول منتصف الليل ولا يستمر
عليه التصويت كما حدث بالمره الماضيه ايام
وساعات هذا ما وعد به لن ننتظر لنرى كيف
تتم العمليه بعد اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع
وبدء فرز الاصوات بعد الساعه السابعه
مساءا هنا بتوقيت اتلانت سنرى كيف تتم هذه
العمليه لكن حسب ما قاله هو في المؤتمر
الصحفي فان عمليه النتائج لن تتاخر كما
حدثت في عام 2020 لما احدثه القانون
الجديد من تغيير على عمليه احتساب اصوات
التصويت بطاقات التصويت همم المبكر
والتصويت عبر البريد باحسابها مبكرا قبل
اغلاق مراكز الاقتراع وبذلك يكون جائزه
للفرز في في الالات الفرز همم
الاليه التي الفرز عندما يتم البدء باظهار
النتائج لدى حسب ما وعد فان النتائج تكون
نهائيه مع منتصف بالنسبه
للنتائج وانت كنت تتحدث عن السباق هذا
السباق الذي يدور بين همم
الديمقراطيه رافاييل بورن هوك وهرش الموقر
وهو لاعب كره قدم امريكيه معروف الى اي
مدى حسب استطلاعات الراي يعني الامر
متقارب ام ان هناك تفوق واضح لاحد
المرشحين
قبل ذلك اسمح لي ان انويه
لتصريح للرئيس الامريكي الذي يقول فيه ان
اولويه الجمهوريين سوف تكون الغاء قانون
خفض التضخم وهذا سيؤدي وهذا خطا كما قال
وسيؤدي الى ارتفاع التكاليف اليوميه تفضل
احمد
استطلاعات الراي عثمان تضع المرشحين في
تنافس محتجب للغايه الفارق هو اقل من هامش
الخطا الذي عاده تحتسب عليه استطلاعات
الراي وهم متساويان تقريبا وان كان هناك
تقدم طفيف لهرش ووكر في نقطه و14 نقطه
بالمئه لكن ما تحدث ايضا به راس
البر
يتوقع ان يجلي مليونين اخذ امريكي بصوتهم
اليوم مع مليونين ونصف المليون من صوته
بشكل مبكر سواء عبر البريد او عبر
الاقتراع المبكر هذا يعني ان نسبه
المشاركه تقترب كثيرا من نسبه عام 2020
والتي كانت 4 مليون و900,000 همم ناخذ
شارك وفي الانتخابات الان نحن على عتبه
اربعه مليون و600 و500,000 ناخذ ما يعني
ان هذا خبر جيد للديمقراطي لان
الديمقراطيين هنا يعوضون على مشاركه واسعه
في المقاطعات الاربعه التي تشكل العاصمه
اطلنطا وضواحيها مثل دي كاب مثل فولتن ومن
جوموري وهنري هذه المقاطعه دي شاركت
بكثافه وان تمكن من تحقيق فج وكبيره بين
اصواته في هذه المقاطعات واصوات خصم هيرش
الووكر فانه سيقترب من حسم هذا سيحسبه
بشكل نهائي اذا تمكن من انتزاع شريحه من
هذه من هؤلاء الناخبين في المقاطعه
الاربعه مع تصويت كثيف في الريف هنا في
ولايه جورجيا معقل الجمهوريين فان ووكر
سيكون هو على عتبه الفوز المراقبون هنا
عثماني يتوقعون ان يتجه هذا السباق الى
جوله اعاده لان قانون ولايه جورجيا يطلب
من اي من كل مرشح ان يتجاوز عتبه ال 50%
ليكون هو المرشح لكن هو الفائز بهذا
المقعد خصوصا ان هناك متنافس ثالث لديه 5%
من الاصوات ومرشح
حزبريتانيا عفوا وهذا المرشح هو من يحصل
على خمسه بالمئه من استطلاعات الراي ولن
وقد لا يسمح بها احد المرشحين من الفوز
باكثر من 50 مليون اذا توقعت في جورجيا ان
تكون غالبيه النتائج اليوم ولكن هناك توقع
فعلا كبير بان تكون هناك جوله ثانيه وهذا
يعني ان النتائج قد لا تكون الا مثلا همم
في ديسمبر على سبيل المثال لنعرف نتيجه
جورجيا ماذا عن بن سيلفينيا
محمد محمد ايضا هناك همم فيها يعني منافسه
شديده بين دكتور اوز مهما المرشح الذي همم
المرشح الجمهوري يعني همم الذي يدعمه او
الذي يدعمه الجمهوريه لانه في البدايه كان
يترشح على انه همم
وفي مقابله الديمقراطيه فطرمان وقد راينا
همم كلى المرشحين يدلي يعني بصوتهما هذا
الصباح
عثمان في الحقيقه توقعات هناك تشير الى
احتمال تاخر نتيجه بنسلفانيا بالهذا هو
سيناريو الذي يتوقعه تقريبا بما في ذلك
حمله جون بيتر من الذي كانت قد اصدرت
مذكره يوم امس تشير فيها الى ان عمليه
احتساب الاصوات قد تستغرق ايام قبل ظهور
النتيجه النهائيه علما ان الامور بالنسبه
لانتخابات حاكم الولايه قد تكون اكثر
وضوحا بالنسبه لجورج شبير وخصمه الجمهوريه
في ضوء استطلاعات الراي التي تشير الى
فارق كبير جدا لصالح جو الشهري وما يعزز
هذه الفرضيه هو انا مفاوضيه مدينه
فيلادلفيا اعلنت صباح هذا اليوم اعاده
العمل بنظام لراسه الاصوات المزدوجه او
بطاقات الاقتراع المزدوجه وهو ما يزيد من
التوقعات باحتمال تاخر نتيجه المسؤولون
سابقا كانوا يؤمنون في ظهور النتيجه او
على الاقل فرز اكبر عدد من الاصوات بحلول
يوم الاربعاء غدا صباحا لكن التوقعات الان
تشير الى ان انتخابات بنسلفانيا خاصه على
مستوى مقعد مجلس الشيوخ بين التتر من واوز
قد لا تظهر هذه الليله المسؤولون هنا في
بنسلفانيا يقولون ان ذلك امر طبيعي جدا
ودعوا ناخبي بن سلفانيا الى الوتر في
العمليه الانتخابيه وبالا يؤدي ذلك الى اي
شك او ريف في نزاهه هذه الانتخابات لكن في
الواقع هناك خشيه من سيناريوهين اذا ما
تاخرت نتيجه الانتخابات هنا في البانيا
اولا مع استمرار فرض الاصوات خاصه
الاصوات عبر البريد قد تزداد المزاعم
والدعايه المضلله والمعلومات بشان نزاهه
الانتخابات والتشكيك فيها مع ان تنسوا
البيانيه كانت واحده من الولايات عث التي
شهد التدفقا كبيرا لمثل هذه المعلومات
السيناريو الثاني هو ان يقوم ميمت اوز
المرشح الجمهوري باعلان النصر خاصه ان
عمليه تعداد واحتساب الاصوات همم سيما
بالنسبه لبطاقه الاقتراع المباشر هي اكثر
سرعه المقارنه
باحتساب الاصوات عبر البريد وهي الاليه
التي يفضلها الناخبون الجمهوريون ذلك قد
يولد مع بدايه التكشف النتائج الاوليه هذه
الليله قد يعطى انطباعا ظاهريا بان مميمه
اوز يتقدم في هذه الانتخابات وهو
السيناريو الذي حذرت منه حمله في مذكرتها
يوم امس قبل ان تتكشف النتيجه النهائيه مع
استمرار فرز همم
جورج كما قلنا في جورجيا انه يبدو مرجحا
ايضا ان تكون هناك جوله ثانيه همم
النتائج حسب استطلاعات اي طبعا لانه في
جورجيا لازم همم يعني المرشح الفائز يجب
ان يحصل على اكثر من 50% اذا لم يصل اي من
المرشحين ستكون هناك جوله ثانيه بالنسبه
لبن سيلفينيا هذه المعطيات التي ذكرتها هل
ترجح بالفعل ايضا ان تتاخر بنسلفينيا في
اعلان النتائج
بكل تاكيد وذلك قد يؤدي الى ضبابيه ايضا
في المشهد السياسي عموما يعني قد يؤدي الى
ضبابيه في من سيسيطر على مجلس الشيوخ في
نهايه المطاف خاصه اذا ماذا ما ذهبت
جورجيا الى جوله اعاده لذلك
هناك تاويل جدا على
الحزبين بالنسبه للديمقراطيين السيطره على
تنس البانيا ومجلس شيوخ مقعد مجلس الشيوخ
سيؤزز فرصاهم في الاحتفاظ بمجلس الشيوخ بل
قد يعزز ويحد من خساره الديمقراطيين في
حال فوزيه وخسارتهم لمقاعد اخرى حاسمه في
ولايه حاسمه لجورجيه بالنسبه للجمهوريين
هم عمليات يدافعون عن هذا المقعد باعتباره
اولا هو مقعد مفتوح بعد تقاعد السنه
الجمهوريه
تومي يحتاجون عمليه
لان الفوز فيها
يسمح لهم بالسيطره على مجلس الشيوخ اذا
فازوا في مقعد واحد على الاقل من بين
الولايات الحاسمه الاخرى اما في حاله
خساره الجمهوريين في التنس فانهم يحتاجون
عمليا الى مقعدين لذلك هناك تركيز شديد
على بنسلفانيا التي تشهد واحده من اكثر
الحملات الانتخابيه تكليتها عثمان بلغت
اكثر من 220 مليون دولار لحد الان على شكل
اعلانات تلفزيونيه
السياسيه
الاكبر في تاريخ الولايات المتحده كما
ذكرت 220 مليون فقط
طبعا الموجه الحمراء اظن السيناريوهات
الاربعه المحتمله النتائج انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه الامريكيه وستعني اكتساحا
للجمهوريين لمجلسين نواب والشيوخ بشكل
لافت حتى في دوائر تعد زرقاء اذا حدثت
ابرز معالم معالم هذا السيناريو ضمن اربع
سيناريوهات محتمله في هذا التقرير
سيناريو اخره للانتخابات النصفيه وهو ان
تفرز فوزا جمهوريا ساحقا او موجه حمراء
وليس صعبا تفسير ذلك مع تحقيق الجمهوريين
مكاسبه ثابته في استطلاعات الراي معادله
قبول الرئيس عند الاربعين المنخفضه مقارنه
بما كانت عليه عند الرؤساء السابقين تتطلب
الموجه الحمراء فقط ان يقرر الناخبون
الذين لم يحسموا امرهم اصواتهم للتعبير عن
موقفهم ورايهم في حزب الرئيس بغض النظر عن
مشاعرهم تجاه شاغل المناصيب الديمقراطيه
الفرديه او ربما يتطلب الامر اقبالا
جمهوريها قويا على نحو غير متوقع يوم
الانتخابات بينما يبقى الناخبون الشباب
وذو الاصول الافريقيه والاسبانيا في
منازلهم باعداد اكبر من ما كان عليه الحال
في انتخابات سابقه وقد يجد حينها شغل مجلس
الديمقراطيون الامنون انفسهم في سباقات
متقاربه بشكل مدهش في اقصى الشمال يمكن
للجمهوريين ان يقلب المناطق الرئيسيه في
فيرجينيا ونورت كارولينا وسيتقدمون ايضا
اكثر في المنطقه الزرقاء ولن تكون سباقه
مجلس الشيوخ في ولايه تينارت كارولين
باوهاي و متقاربه وقد يتجنب الجمهوريون
جوله الاعاده في جورجيا في سباق مجلس
الشيوخ ويفوزون فيديوهات ومن شان ذلك ان
يجعلهم يسيطرون على المجلس
ورغم ان الرئيس يتمتع بصلاحيات دستوريه
واسعه في مجال السياسه الخارجيه فان
الجمهوريين قادرون على عرقله مساعده
دبلوماسيه بحجم التمويل في مجلس النواب او
رفض التصديق على اي معاهدات في مجلس
الشيوخ ان نجحوا في السيطره على غرفتي
الكونغ سلمى المزيد مع تقرير مراسلنا في
واشنطن محمد العالمي
هدد زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
والمرشح لرئاسه المجلس كيف المقارثي بان
المجلس تحت رئاسته لن يوفر شيكا على بياض
لمساعده اوكرانيا
وبحكمه سيطره المجلس على الاعتمادات
الماليه في حال انتزاع حزبه خمسه مقاعد
فقط من الديمقراطيين بامكانه ايجاده
متاعبه للبيت الابيض استجابه للمد الصاعدي
في الحزب الجمهوري
ويشير
التاثير بين مؤيد الترامب الذين يشترطونه
وجود مصلحه امريكيه
تبرر التدخل الامريكي لكنهم لا يرون ذلك
في حرب روسيا و اوكرانيا
بروزه اوكرانيا نقطه الخلافيه على المسرح
الدولي خلال الحمله الانتخابيه لا يمنع من
بروز نقاط اخرى ان انتقل الكونجرس الى
ايدي الجمهوريين من التعامل مع العلاقه
المتوفره اصلا مع الصين الى التعامل مع
منظمه اوبك بلس خاصه بعد قرارها خفض
الانتاج وما صاحبه من انتقادات من الاداره
الامريكيه
لكن سيطره الجمهوريين على الكونغرس قد
تعني اطلق رصاصه الرحمه على جهود البيت
الابيض لاحياء الاتفاقيه النوويه مع ايران
بل من غير المستبعد ان ينضم اليهم مشارعون
ديمقراطيون صفحه المفاوضات مع طهران
لان اداره بيضا حاولت بحسن النيه العوده
الى اتفاقيه تفتقد لتاييد شعبي لكن تاكد
الاوروبيين ان الخطا في ايران وليس في
واشنطن لهذا لدينا جبهه الموحده ضد كل من
ايران وروسيا سيطره الجمهورينا على
دبلوماسيه الرئيس لكنها لن تحرمه من
صلاحياته الدستوريه في مجال السياسه
الخارجيه بل قد تتحولوا علاقات امريكا
بالعالم الى ملاده الاخيره لان اجنده
الداخليه
سيعتريها الشلل والجمود فيما تبقى من
ولايته الرئاسيه محمد العلمي الجزيره
واشنطن
الينا في الاستوديو الدكتور خليل العناني
محلل الجزيره للشؤون الانتخابات النصفيه
واستاد العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
اهلا وسهلا وكذلك في الاستديو الدكتور
الباحثين في معهد واشنطن والمسؤول السابق
عن قسم سوريا في مجلس الامن القومي اهلا
وسهلا والدكتور عبد الله الشايجي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت ومؤلف
كتاب مبادئ السياسه الخارجيه للرؤساء
الامريكيين ينضم الينا من الكويت اهلا
وسهلا
الرئيس ترامب ما هي محددات السياسه
الخارجيه بالنسبه للحزب الجمهوري فيما
يتعلق بالشرق الاوسط
العناصر الاساسيه بالنسبه الى السياسه
الخارجيه للجمهوريين في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط تركزوا على ايران وامن اسرائيل
هناك مخاوف مرتبطه ايضا بامن الطاقه
وخصوصا بالمنطقه الخليج العربي نقطه
اساسيه بالنسبه الى الرئيس ترامب كانت
احتواء ايران في المنطقه من المنظور
النووي وايضا في الميدان في بلدان العربيه
المتعدده
ماذا عن الديمقراطيين صحيح انت عملت في
اداره الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب ولكن
انت ملم ايضا بالسياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
بشكل عام وبالتالي الديمقراطيون ما هي
محددات وسياساتهم خارجيه نحو الشرق الاوسط
مشابهه الطاقه ايران وامن اسرائيل
ولكنهم يتابعون السياسه بطريقه مختلفه من
خلال التفاوض مع الايرانيين بشكل اساسي
وايضا بنسبه الى التعامل مع اسرائيل شجعوا
اسرائيل على
الاتفاقي مع دول النجاره في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بنسبه الى الغاز ايضا همم ما حصل
في لبنان مؤخرا والخطط بنقل الغاز عبر
سوريا الى لبنان وايضا بنسبه الى طاقه من
الخليج الحزب الديمقراطي يختلف في مقاربته
حيث انه يركز على عدم استخدام الوقود
الاحفوري
والانباتات الكربونيه وهذا ما يختلف مع
اداره ترامب
اذا ما روحنا الى العاجله تشاهدونه على
الشاشه وهو تصريح للرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدنا الذي قال بوارثنا فوضى كبيره وقدنا
طبعا من الاداره السابقه وتمكنا كما يقول
من اعاده بناء الاقتصاد من الاسفل الى
الاعلى ولكن دكتور خليل كيف تعامل مع
سياسه همم الولايات المتحده في الشرق
الاوسط من الاسفل الى الاعلى ام من الاعلى
للاسفل كيف يمكن ان تصفها
جاء من خلال جلده طموحه جدا في الشرق
الاوسط تحدث عن انجاز اتفاقنا اول مع
ايران او على قال اعاده تفعيل اتفاق
القديمه 2015 تحدث عن همم امكانيه دعم
للانظمه الخليجيه والحلفاء في المنطقه
تحدث عن امكانيه ايجاد حل الاسرائيلي تحدث
عن دعم المفتاح حقوق الانسان من كل هذه
الاهداف الكبرى اولا ليس هناك يعني تقدم
في التفاقه النووي الايراني ليس هناك
التقدم على الصعيد الفلسطيني بالعكس هناك
دعم غير محدود لاسرائيل ليس هناك دعم
الديموقراطيع حقوق الانسان همم وبالتالي
هو لم يحقق شي حتى هذه اللحظه نتيجه لي او
عمالين عاملين رئيسيين عامل الاولاني
متعلق بالحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا والتي
جاءت بشكل مفيد جدا وبالتالي نقلت اهتمام
كله باتجاه روسيا الامر الثاني المتعلق
بالصراع مع الصين وهناك تركيز شديد على
هذه المساله وجاء هذا الموضوع في اكثر من
الوثيقه امريكيه حول النظر باعتبارها
تحديا استراتيجيا واقتصاديا وعسكريا
لامريكا في المستقبل وحاليا
طبعا كمان شهد هناك تصريحات للرئيس
الامريكي جوبرايد ان نروي الى تصريحه اخر
يقول فيها اكثر من 300 من 300 مرشح جمهوري
يشككون في نزاهه الانتخابات ولا يعترفون
بالخساره وطبعا قال ان ادارته عامله تعيين
اشخاص من الاقليه الافريقيه الامريكيه
معروف بالافريكان امريكا اكثر من اي اداره
سابقه دكتور شاي جيه نفس السؤال وجهه لك
كيف يعني او ما هي محددات العلاقه مع
الشرق الاوسط بالنسبه لادا الرئيس
اولا ثم سنتحدث عن الجانب الجمهوري
او او انت كيف تابعتها وكيف يعني رقبته
اريد ان اعلق بعض النقاط المهمه يعني هذا
الانتخابات المترم الانتخابات التجديد
النصفي لا يوجد فيها اي اي موضوع يهم
الناقل الامريكي له صله بالسياسه الخارجيه
اذا تابعنا استطلاعات الراي التي تجرى منذ
شهرين او اكثر جميع القضايا قضايا محليه
وهذا شيء متوقع لقضايا التضخم قضايا
الغلاء قضايا الوقود قضايا التعليم
الجرائم التشكيك بالانتخابات لاول مره
الانتخابات تجرى
والديمقراطيه على المحك يعني هذا غير
مسبوق في امريكا راعيه الحريات والدقيق
اذا سمحتي يا دكتور يعني قد لا تؤثر
السياسه الخارجيه في قرار الناقب الامريكي
بشكل كبير ولكن قرار الناقب الامريكي ومن
ينتقبه سوف يؤثر على سياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط وهذا ما نحن
نناقشه الان في النقاش
صحيح ولهذا السبب الرؤساء الامريكان لا لا
يعني لا يعطون اهميه للسياسه الخارجيه لكن
السياسه الخارجيه تفرض نفسها على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في ينظر الي ان قوه
متردده وصفها كيسنجر في كتابه النظام
العالمي قوه متراجعه في المنطقه راينا نحن
الان كيف انسحبت من افغانستان يعني حلفاء
امريكا في الشرق الاوسط وفي الخليج العربي
لا يثقون الان بنوايا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي تبدو منهامك داخليا
ريتشارد هاوس عنده مقوله مهمه اذا كانت
امريكا متفككه ضعيفه ومنقسمه على نفسها
كما نرى الان في هذه الانتخابات فكيف
ستكون قويه وتبادر في الشان الخارجي وتر
وتقنع او او تطمئن حلفائها الخلقين يعني
راينا الاشتباك الذي حدث بلس راينا التهجم
على السعوديه من الرئيس ومن قيادات حزبه
والتوعد بمراجعه العلاقه معها بعد ما قررت
قبل شهر تخفيض الانتاج مليونين برميل
فلهذا السبب هناك نظره بان يمكن
الديمقراطيه اقل
ارتباطا مع قضايا المتقايرون البعض ان
الجمهوريون ان الجمهوريين هم اكثر ارتباطا
خاصه انهم قد حرم همم مع تحالف عالمي تحت
رايات الامم المتحده تحرير الكويت وكذلك
قالوا تحالف لاسقاط مع بريطانيا نظام صدام
حسين ولكن اذكرني يتاملون بالجمهوريين انه
عندما قصفت ايران واذرعها دجاج وخريص في
المنطقه الشرقيه في السعوديه في سبتمبر
2019 لم يحرك ترامب ساكنا والعندما قصفت
صفوان واحرقت ناقلات نفط في الخليج لم
يفعل شيء قبل ايران اسقطت له اغلى طائره
درون في في في في الاسطول او في سلاح
الطيران الامريكي فلهذا السبب يعني قضايا
الشرق الاوسط ستكون مراوحه مكانها
يعني
الامريكيه وبدون يحاول ان يعني يصححها نوع
هذا يقودني لسؤال سوف اساله للدكتور انجلو
تابلر هل قرار الانسحاب من الشرق الاوسط
وقضايا الى حد كبير هو اذا قرار يتفق عليه
الطرفان الجمهوري والديمقراطي وليس قرار
طرف بعينه
لا نتحدث عن اتفاقا بين الطرفين ولكن هناك
الشعور في كلا الجانبين الجمهوريه
والديمقراطي بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بدل الجهود كبيره واموال
وعتيد
في المنطقه
وان الولايات المتحده تتعرض للضغوط على
المستوى القدرات الماليه وهي بحاجه في
الوقت نفسه ان تركز على اسيا وعلى الامن
الاسيوي المشكله في هذه المقاربه طبعا هي
اننا نحن نتحدث عن هذا الموضوع من خمسه
عشره سنه منذ اتيته الى واشنطن سواء كانت
الاداره ديمقراطيه او جمهوريه وبالتالي
اذا ما اردنا حتى ولو اردنا ان نبتعد عن
الشرق الاوسط او اوروبا باتجاه هذا لا
يحصل همم
بانتفاضه في منطقه العربيه ثوره او غسول
العراق او غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا هذه وتتغير
وتتقل الولايات المتحده همم في تلك
المنطقه ولكن السؤال هو ما هي التكلفه
او لسبب اقدم ربما وهو عدم وجود حل عادل
للقضيه الفلسطينيه وكما تعلم كثيرون يلقون
على الجانب الامريكي المنحاس بوضوح يسمح
لي اقول هذا الكلام وخلفي كونجرس وهنا في
واشنط
ن
الصحيه
التدخل الامريكيه لمحاوله التوصل الى حل
الانسانيه بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
هذه المحاوله لم تنجح والتدخل بنسبه الى
برنامج ايران النوويه حتى اللحظه الراهنه
لم ينجح ولم يوقف التدخل الايراني والتوسع
الايراني في المنطقه ومن ناحيه اخرى هناك
بعض الاوجه الايجابيه على سبب المثال
السعر النفط وهو جزء اساسي من حياه الجميع
سواء كان في الولايات المتحده الصين او
الخليج سعر همم نفط وتامين النفط هو من
بين نجاحات طويله الامد منذ
كما قال الدكتور انجلو بالفعل يعني الحديث
عن انسحاب الولايات المتحده من المنطقه
يتم الحديث فيه منذ فتره طويله وهو يقول
الامر ليس انها لا تريد الانسحاب ولكن
تبدو غير قادره انا يختلف مع مقوله انك
انسحاب امريكي لمنطقه العربيه عثمان نحن
دائما نسميه اعاده تموضع في المنطقه
العربيه بمعنى ان هناك قد يكون اولويات
اخرى امريكا ومتعلقه بالصراع على الساحه
العالميه الصراع مع روسيا الصراع مع الصين
لكن ايضا هناك مصالح امريكيه استراتيجيه
في المنطقه العربيه خذ مثلا على سبيل
المثال لدينا في المنطقه العربيه ما يقرب
ما لا يقل عن 70,000 جندي امريكي موجود في
المنطقه العربيه من الامارات الى الكويت
الى العراق الى سوريا نمره واحد نمره
اثنين هناك اتفاقات بين امريكا من الدول
العربيه فما يتعلق مظله امنيه لان هناك
كان يطلق عليه الشبح الايراني او تهديد
ايران في المنطقه العربيه من الصعب جدا
تخيل انك تخلي امريكي
تهديدات بوجود احتمال همم هجوم ايراني على
السعوديه تم تحرير قوات امريكيه في
المنطقه العربيه من اجل صد اي هجوم محتمل
من ايران على السعوديه الامر الثالث متعلق
بمثابه النفط والطاقه هذا امر
استدل امريكا من الصعب امريكا ان تترك
الهديه المنطقه في حاله صول النادي يؤثر
على السوق العالميه النفط بالتالي يؤثر
على المواطن الامريكي فيما يتعلق الاسعار
خلال اخر خمس ست شهور عن حرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا خاصه في ظل العقوبات على على
روسيا وهي منتج كبير للنصر هناك ارتفاع
اسعار النفط وبالتالي انا ليست مع مقوله
انا كان سحاب امريكي او تحول استراتيجي في
موقف في امريكا
او تحول او عدد تم وضع في المنطقه من اجل
مساله اخرى متعلقه بالصراع مع قوى كوبري
الصين طبعا دكتور شرجي كما تعلم مجلس
الشيوخ له دور كبير في السياسه الخارجيه
همم الامريكيه ايا كانت النتيجه كيف تتوقع
ان تنعكس على السياسه الامريكيه الاذاعه
المنطقه
لا شك طبعا يعني مجلس الشيوخ هو دستوريا
مفوض ومخول بان يلعب الدور الرئيسي في
الشان الخارجي وليس مجلس النواب ولكن لو
سمحت بعجال لا يوجد انسحاب امريكي يتفق مع
صديقه يا دكتور خليل العناني يوجد ان كفاء
الاسميه 10 سنوات
المهمه لان امن الخليج وامن الطاقه مهم
جدا للاقتصاد العالمي بما في الاقتصاد
الامريكي دراما ان امريكا الدوله الاولى
المنتجه في العالم بسبب النفط والغاز
والاحفوري بالنسبه الى مجلس الشيوخ طبعا
مجلس الشيوخ او حسب الدستور
مكلف
بجميع المصادق على جميع الترشيحات للرئاسه
الذي يترحها الرئيس سواء كان في السلطه
التنفيذيه او في السلطه الدكتور هل سيتغير
شيء ام سيعمل الحسبان معا ل ل لسياسات
ربما عليها يعني نعم الخساره الكبيره
للمبايدن والديمقراطيه سيكون اذا خسروا
مجلس الشيوخ يعني هذه ضربه قاسمه ستكون
وقد تنهي مستقبله السياسي بيرشح ل 24 مجلس
الشيوخ عنده الكثير من الاوراق يمكن ان
يلعبها ولكن يعني ما اعتقد بوجوده ترامب
يعني مرشحين المتشددين الى فاز هرش الووكر
واذا فاز محمد اوز واخرين يدعمهم همم
وكذلك في اريزونا فهؤلاء يعني يعمدون الى
افشال خطط الرئيس نوديمقراطيين لضمان
خسارتهم همم اكبر وتكبيرهم اكثر وخسارتهم
المرشح الديمقراط سواء كانها بايضا او كان
مرشح ديمقراطي اخر ان لا يفوز بالانتخابات
الرئاسه بعرقله جميع مشاريعهم جميع همم
قوانين كذلك ترشيحاتهم ل- همم
للسلطه التنفيذيه وكذلك السلطه القضائيه
ويتحول رئيس ايضا الى كما يسمى بطلع ارجاء
لين بدك فريزيدن للسنتين القادمتين ويضمن
خساره الديمقراطين وفوز جماعه ترامب
والميغا ترامب دكتور
وطبعا هذا يعني سيخضع للنقاش كاثير وكبير
في ساعات المقبله في كل الاحوال درجه
العاده ان الرئيس همم يخسر في سنتين ال-
ال- القليين انتخابات الكونجرس في
الولايات المتحده تاريخيا شكرا لك الدكتور
عبدالله الشارجي من الكويت دكتور خليل
العناني والدكتور
شكرا جزيلا المزيد عن معركه السيطره على
الكونغرس بهذا التقرير اللي بس انا كويس
هذا احد اهم مفاصل مراكز الصناعه القرار
الامريكي وهنا تحتضم معركه الانتخابات
النصفيه
الديمقراطيون يامونا ابقاء سيطراتهم على
الكونجرس بمجلسين الشيوخ والنواب
الجمهوريون يسعون لاستعاده الاغلبيه ان لم
يكن على الكونجرس بغرفته فمجلس النواب على
الاقل
كل عامين يخوض كافه اعضاء مجلس النواب
المكون من
435 مقعدا معركه انتخابيه لاعاده الترشح
الديمقراطيون يشغلون الان 220 منها مقابل
212 مقعدا للجمهوريين اضافه الى ثلاثه
مقاعد شاغره يحتاج الجمهوريون الى خمسه
مقاعد فقط لنيل الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
اما مجلس الشيوخ فيتالف من 100 مقعد ولايه
العضو فيه سته اعوام لذا يخوض ثلث المجلس
كل عامين معركه اعاده الترشح هذا العام
تتركز المنافسه على 35 مقعدا واحدا وعشرون
منها يشغلها جمهوريون واربعه عشره يشغلها
ديمقراطيون
تشتد المنافسه لنيل الاغلبيه بين الحزبين
في ثلاث ولايات هي جورجيا وبانسلفينيا
ونفادا كما يحتدم السباق ايضا في كل من
اريزونا ووسكونسن
كي ينالوا الاغلبيه يحتاج الجمهوريون الى
الفوز بمقعد واحد فقط فمجلس الشيوخ الحالي
منقسم بالمناصفه بين الحزبين مع كون نائبه
الرئيس الامريكي كامله حارس السلطه
المرجحه لكافه الديمقراطيين
يتولى الكونجرس الامريكي يسن تشريعات
والقوانين لتصبح نافذه بعد ان يمررها كلا
المجلسين ويوقعها الرئيس كما تعود
للكونجرس مسؤوليه تمرير موازنه تمويل
الحكوميه
الاختلاف في عمل المجلسين يكمن في ان
لمجلس الشيوخي سلطه النظر والتصديق على
ترشيحات الرئيسي للقضاه والمناصب الحكوميه
اما مجلس النواب فلديه سلطه بدء تحقيقات
قد تفضي لتوجيه المجلس تهاما لرئيس البلاد
احد المسؤولين بانتهاك القانون ومن ثم
محاكمته في مجلس الشيوخ
اما الان فعوده الى حسن وبقيه اخبار
الحساء
[موسيقى]
شكرا لي يا عثمان الفرح وباقي الزملاء في
واشنطن في تطورات الجديده
مع الولايات المتحده بشان اوكرانيا
جورنال خلال الايام الماضيه
لدى الامم المتحده ليندا
واشنطن لاوكرانيا سيستمر
في الحرب واضافت ان الاوكرانيين هم من
يقررون مدى استعدادهم لاجراء اي مفاوضات
نعم للمفاوضات دون شروط مسبقه باستثناء
الشرط الاساسيه واحد حسن النيه من كيف
هكذا جاء اعلان موسكو على الجلوس مجددا
الى طويله الحوار مع الاوكرانيين في ايام
العسكري للحرب الداميه هل ذلك ممكن واي
دور ستؤديه واشنطن
الخارجيه الروسي اندريه
هي التي تبنت قنونا يمنعها من اجراء
مفاوضات سلميه مع روسيا وان بلاده تعلن
دائما استعدادها لمثل هذه المفاوضات التي
لم تقطع بسبب روسيا كان الرئيس الاوكرانيا
على
انفاق اي محادثات مع بوتن منعلمه واذا انه
ترك الباب م لاجراء محادثات مع روسيا لذلك
جاء التعليقات مستشار زلينسكي على
التقارير الصحفيه الامريكيه بشان
المفاوضات متناغمه جدا مع هذا المبدا
اوضحها ميخائيل بولياك انكيف لم ترفض ابدا
التفاوض وموقفها معروف ينبغي سحب القوات
الروسيه اولا قبل الحديث عن اي تفاوض
مضيفا جمله نحن واضحون في تقييمنا سنتحدث
مع الرئيس القادم لروسيا
احجم كل طرفين عن الخوض بالتفصيل فيما
ذكرته تقارير واشنطن بوست
على اي مستوى جرت الاتصالات المباشره وغير
المباشره بين الامريكيين والروس في الاونه
الماضيه وهل فعلا ضغطت واشنطن على كياب
للقبول بالجلوسي الى طاوله الحوار حتى في
ظل وجود القوات الروسيه على ارضها
برد مستشار الامن القومي جاكسون المحادثات
السريه التي اجراها مع كبار المسؤولين
الروس لانها كانت تهدف الى الحد من
المخاطر وتقليص احتمال وقوع كارثه مثل
استخدام السلاح النووي
في زياره الاكياف اصبحت مندوبه الولايات
المتحده لدى الامم المتحده ليندا
توماسكي الولايات المتحده مستعده للوقوف
الى جانب اوكرانيا طالما لازم الامر الحد
قولها مضيفه ان اي مفاوضات يجب ان تكون مع
اوكرانيا وقادتها يقررون مدى استعدادهم
لذلك من كل اللقاء فضلت المسك التركيز على
مساله ضروره تنديد اتفاق تصدير الحبوب بعد
التاسعه عشر من الشهر الكريم
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها صبنت
تسعه هجمات للقوات الاوكرانيه في المحورين
الشماليه والغربيه
للقوات المسلحه
الجويه
فوق مياه البحر الاسود دون اعطاء مزيدا من
التفاصيل
قال حاكم لبنان
قوات مشاه البحريه الاوكرانيه قصفت مستودع
الوقود للقوات الروسيه في قريه ديبروفا في
المقاطعه ونشر غايدي صورا قال انها
للمستودع الروسي بعد قصفه مضيفا ان
الاستدافه كان دقيقا وتسبب في تدمير مخزون
القوه الروسيه من الوقود وموده التشحين في
المستودع بالكامل
نشرت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
اوكرانيين كانوا يخططون لتنفيذ ما سمتها
عمليات الارهابيه في مدينه خلصن الواقعه
تحت السيطره الروسيه والتي تتعرض لقصف
اوكرانيا متكرر
واضافت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه ان اجهزه
الامن كما كانت ايضا من ابطال سياره مفخخه
وفقا لوكاله ريا نفوستي الروسيه
قناه ستريمو صواف نائب رئيس الاداره
العسكريه والمدنيه التي نصبتها روسيا في
مقاطعه خرسان ان عمليات الاجلاء الجماعيه
لسكان من مدينه خيرسون انتهت وبامكاني من
تبقى من السكان التقدم بطلب فرديا للاجلاء
الواقعه على الضفه اليمنى باتجاه الضفه
اليسرى اكثر امانا الان الاجلاء الجماعي
للسكان انتهى ومن يريد الاجلاء بصوره
فرديه فعليه ان يتقدم بذلك عبر الخط
الساخن في غضون الاسابيع او الايام
المقبله سيتضح الوضع اما ان يتم تحرير
ميكو لايف او غير سون قريبا جدا فهذا
المحور اصبح مركز الاهتمام وهو مهم ايضا
من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه
متواصل بوي
[موسيقى]
الى التطوراتي في باكستان حيث افاده مراسل
الجزيره ان مؤيدين لحزب انصاف يحاولون
اغلاق الطريق السريع الرابط بين العاصمه
اسلام اباد واقليم البنجاب في الوقت الذي
تستعينه سلطاته بالشرطه وقوات الدرك
للحقولي دون اغلاق
ثناء الله انه وجه الحكمتين المحليتين في
اقليم البنجاب وخيبر بفتح الطريق السريع
الرابط بين العاصمه اسلام اباد والاقليمين
وذلك بعد قيام انصار حزب انصاف باغلاقه
ودعى ثناء الله في مؤتمر صحفي حكومتي
الاقليميين الى عدم توفير الحمايه لمن
اسمائهم بمسيري الشرق
دكتور مجمد
في البلد ولا طالما شجبنا ذلك اما الان
فاننا كحكومه مركزيه امرنا الحكومه
المحليتين في اقليميه البنجاب وخيبر شفهيا
وكتابيا بفتح الطريق السريع الرابط بين
العاصمه والاقليمين وبشكل فوري ولقد امرنا
الحكومه كذلك بعدم توفير حمايه
الشعب
الاتحاديه
تتوزع فيها السند وبلوشستان والبنجاب
وخيبر وكشمير كل هذه الاقاليم تتمتعوا
ببعض السلطات بمعزل عن الحكومه المركزيه
في العاصمه اسلام اباد
حكماته اقاليم البنجاب وخيبر وكشمير تخضع
لسلطه حزب انصاف او لسلطه المتحالفين معه
الملاحظه ان الاقاليم ثلاثه تحيط
الجغرافيا بالعاصمه اسلام اباد وتشكل طوقا
حولها وهو ما قد يستفيد منه حزب انصاف
بشان مسيرتهم الاحتجاجيه
الى العراق حيث قال رئيس الوزراء محمد شيع
السوداني ان توقيت مقتل المواطن الامريكي
ستيفن ادوارد في منطقه الكراده ببغداد يوم
امس يحمل علامات استفهام كثيره واضاف
السوداني ان الاجهزه المختصره تجري
تحقيقاتها لمعرفه الجنات وكانت مواقع
اعلاميه عراقيه افادت امس ان المواطن
الامريكي
في شارع الصناعه بحي الكراده في بغداد
وقالت مصادر في الشرطه لرويترز ان ادوارد
يعملوا مدرسا للغه الانجليزيه